intergalactic time travel oh gee maps
and player loadouts let's talk about
season 9 a part night battle royale
welcome to PlayStation granade it's that
great time of the season just before the
new content drops and we all look for
clues and teasers as to what's going to
happen next we have a pretty good track
record predicting husks a castle or to a
volcano three seasons before it actually
happened pets and even tanks okay I got
that one completely wrong we got cannons
but if you squint a little bit they look
like small tank no they no they don't
sorry about that one before we start
there is usually a ridiculous skin in
the battle past such as the banana or a
tomato headed vampire if you can predict
the silly skin for season 9 I'll add you
to my friends list and gift you V bucks
good luck my prediction is an alien with
huge testicle tentacles tentacles please
don't do monetize me YouTube moving on
quickly there's something I do know is
on its way but I'm not sure if it will
make it into this season or next season
it's loadouts I need these in my life
does this ever happen to you you decide
to change a character but then you also
need to change their battling their
pickaxe their raps their trails it
becomes a part-time job sometimes with
loadouts we can simply set up a
character with every element perfectly
the way we want it then simply press
save your bright pink character with
pink wraps pink trails pink axe you you
get the idea I like pink I'm a grown man
anyway your character will be saved but
whenever you want to take them into
battle again season 9 is here in but a
few days and unlike previous seasons we
don't have the hype machine in full flow
this is because back in season 3 one of
the developers revealed the story has
only been written up to season 9 which
means we've now hit the point of no
return but luckily there are so many
possible ways to move the story forward
but which will be right so where are we
right now the vault has opened we
selected the drum gun and the volcano
was instantly triggered and spat vitriol
everywhere so let's start with that
fault
have you seen Donald mustard on Twitter
he's the creative director of Epic Games
and recently he tweeted this just after
the event which by the way didn't happen
for me 20 minutes I stood there like a
simpleton
she is epic anyway Donald said agency
and choice as such fascinating concepts
especially in the context of narrative
so to break that down
Donald is suggesting that from this
event forward we the players will be
making the key decisions about the state
of the game both from a story point of
view and from a competitive standpoint
so if you've opted for the drum gun good
for you
do what you want to do not what a twitch
streamer tells you to do it's our game
we can break it if we want to before I
go on a rant we are able to confirm that
the vault is staying for at least the
next season so we decide what comes out
and also watch goes in
I can't wait to vote to get rid of the
ballers I hate those bloody things but
you may love them
keeping with the vaults did you notice
the teacher's desk inside or if you
prefer the architect of the island the
person making the decisions they are not
here they've left us to be in charge and
depending how badly was due they'll
likely come back and drool over as yet
again on the desk is a mask look closely
it resembles a ninja skins from this
season but also intergalactic in nature
with hints of Megaman and Ultraman - and
this is my bold prediction intergalactic
time travel but hear me out him yup the
theory of time travel has been brought
up many times in fortnight the rocket
event used micro time travel to move
around the map before destroying the
dome which protects us Kevin the cube
with the og hero of this story then
showed up and showed us another
dimension the awesome butterfly event
and those that can understand quantum
physics come on we all know quantum
physics right anyway you'll know
interdimensional travel and time travel
use the same theory just ask the
Avengers and now we've been dragged into
the vault which looks once again like an
alternative dimension so here it is
here's where I think we're going the
original map will be introduced during
an LTM maybe from season zero or maybe
from the brilliance of season four I
don't know but we have hit the point in
advertising called nostalgia marketing
which uses the stronger older days of a
product and brings that into present day
to invoke those ojik feelings I'm sure
when you think back to your first live
event or the first time you won a game
the feeling is simply awesome time
travel through L TMS will relive those
memories and begin to wipe away the
negative culture which is surrounding
the game at the moment it also adds to
the storyline which for me keeps me
involved don't feel as though we'll be
stuck in the past though I'm expecting
both directions to the future and the
past
damn that does sound good hold up hold
up as I'm editing this the first teaser
has arrived the future is unknown
perfect timing
notice the neon colors every time we've
seen time travel or dimension shifts in
fortnight they've been accompanied by
that color palette time to get height
this is under by the way cielos under
in time by the way think about using
code a damaru when you buy the season
nine battle pass it helps me out
massively and you'll be immortalized in
video form like these sexy monkey
fluffers self-promotion I feel so dirty
but I do appreciate the support thank
you
you'd like end a few things in season
eight I was expecting yet never
materialized but have so much potential
so let's quickly look over them now so
we know about the Ice King attempting to
keep the island in perpetual frost
before the prisoner broke free and
started to heat up the area well this
season we even locked the prisoners
Harbinger the destructive boss of ruin
but at present we haven't seen that
storyline move forward
I personally expected an LTM in which
both of the Thrones must be protected
before the opposition destroy them but
alas it never happened
so what could happen next is the
storyline over what we can do is we'll
break it down and that's a pun you'll
get it in a moment during the latest
live event the volcano took a shot at
polar peak cracking the side of the
structure which got me thinking where
would it go if it collapsed well that
legend of a leaker fought Tory has since
discovered an additional breakage in the
mountain which makes the following much
more likely I expect greasy Grove to
return over the next two seasons but get
this what if the medieval castle falls
down into greasy Grove making a new
location we've seen tilted and retailed
destroyed and likely rebuilt during the
coming seasons so this is a great time
to bring back an OG greasy Grove with a
few differences but what could we call
it gothic Grove greasy peak yeah let's
let's not call it that hashtag crazy
peak in the comments so new locations
are a must have you noticed that Viking
Valhalla is slowly taking over snobby
Shores
creating a real Viking village well
fought night history has shown as one
thing that when something moves
destruction is just behind the derp
burger moved after greasy Grove just
before it was flooded and frozen pizza
pit moved because of a time-traveling
stone pyramid hey time travel again the
parachutes at flush factory saw that
area smashed into oblivion something is
going to happen here what could it be
could the ship fall down due to volcanic
or is something bigger about to happen
we shall see around this time of the
season I usually jump back into
fortnight save the world and this is due
to most of the aspects of Battle Royale
first being tested in saved the world
the hoverboards the cannons the dust
devils which became geysers but at
present saved the world seems to have
been given up on which is a bloody shame
but as a positive we were given another
gift for save the world players one of
which was this sexy pink axe
it's vinda tech have you ever heard of
them it's where those VBox come from
they're from save the world
Binda tech money's dr. Vindi Minh is a
character we try and locate in save the
world he's an inventor creating weapons
and defensive mechanisms to save
humanity
of course there's motive than that but
lately his tech is popping up more and
more in Battle Royale
making the timelines much closer the
bunkers under buildings around the
island have been regularly in save the
world for years now as we uncover the
events which destroyed the earth oh and
that reminds me have you noticed the
bunker under the house in retail cannot
be destroyed the panels will not budge
could this link to an event next season
anyway I digress
I'll save the world becomes closer to
free-to-play the timelines should
converge and tell us once and for all
how did the Hunger Games island get here
and what are we trying to prove but if
you're not into narrative you won't give
a crap and I understand that but I need
closure all right the rocket vinda tech
the vault vendor tech my lovely pink axe
window tech that robot when you die
Binda tech V bucks that you spend all
the time Vint you get the idea move on
before I go save the world man let's
look at leakers tweets this is hype X
who put out a tweet about things he
expects I don't think there's much proof
behind these yet but one stood out to me
hats this would be the perfect item to
add to keep us buying V books and
spending them with haste this would also
make sense as removable Helms became a
key element in season 8 the natural
progression is Morehead where if you
ever played Team Fortress 2 you know
that hats took over the world of Micro
Tran
actions building the road which bought
night now walks upon I don't know about
you but if I can give my girl him a a
backwards a bright pink cap I'd be all
over that although I'd much prefer my
luchador mask
come on epoch I know you don't watch
this but help a brother out
give me my mask high pecks also
suggested raps for the battle bus which
I can completely understand we want to
personalize our games and epic games
want to make so much money they can dive
into it like Scrooge McDuck
it's a win-win here let's quickly
revisit those other bunkers it's been a
year since the first bunker arrived and
we all speculated what the heck it was
for then at Christmas 2018 another one
appeared hidden under a volley of ice
and snow on an abandoned Island what the
heck are they for it must be something
why would we stubbornly whack our
weapons against a block of ice for days
will these be rifts to other areas of
the map are simply here to troll us
please let me know what you think
because I need closure on this and to
finish my usual prediction with zero
evidence zero thought I predicted
elemental battles last season yeah that
didn't go well for me but in my defense
technically a volcano destroying a town
is an elemental battle ok it's not I'm
just saying that to turn this frown
upside down
anyway my blind prediction this season
is customizable sprays and those
terrible little emotes we throw up
granted this is likely a long way away
but why the hell not well the main
reason is copyright and means and to be
honest everyone will draw a dick it's
just in our nature
but what if trusted creators could
upload sprays for their community I
kinda really like this one massive coded
Amaru in huge letters anyway I got this
suggestion from mark nuts or credit is
not mine it is thanks mark
right I am sure you're sick of my
disgusting voice by now so I'll get out
of your ear host if you made it to the
end of the video please right where you
play in the comments ps4 PC mobile
switch Xbox I would love to know where
you play and we have cross play so let's
do something with that next season I'm
Adam from PlayStation granade please
think about using my code when you grab
the season 9 battle pass in return I'll
make marfox
what say you thanks for your time I'll
see you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]